listen to the language rudy uses here  okay be you you really have to this is  one of those it's linguistically  important to listen to the words used  and the president put out the first uh  notice  of this rally which actually was  somewhere in mid-december for a january  6 rally  on the day that the electoral college  vote was going to be taken  the whole purpose of it was  a rally in support of the president's uh  bid  for  electoral votes in the sense that  he had proven and shown that he had  really won these states and he was being  deprived of these states  unfairly and illegally  a bid the point of the rally was to  support trump's bid for electoral votes  you don't bid  for electoral votes you either won them  or you didn't